[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [__]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [__]
eating [__] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [__] them
[Music]
Russia Russia Russia Russia Russia
better than China I guess I don't know
I was paying close tension to the Mutiny
the Insurrection the coup attempt
in Russia over the weekend and it
appears that it is not over it appears
that uh Vladimir Putin has uh shown that
he is he is weak and shown his
weaknesses
um rather pagosia is still alive or not
it seems that he just made a statement
if you're not familiar if you're not up
to speed what happened was is the
mercenary group Wagner we've talked
about them before here on the show with
Texas Paul
um I have to go back and re-watch
exactly what Texas Paul said but I think
he got it he usually Nails it on the
head he nailed on the head here that
when the Wagner group was getting
discouraged with the Russian
federation's army and the way they are
operating they were starting to pull
back in Ukraine and um it seems that
pagosia who this is funny did you know
that this guy is an oligarch and the
reason how he's got all this money to
have this private Army
is because he's a caterer I'm not
[__] you he's known as Putin's Chef
he's a caterer
um and apparently he his company
supplies
all the school lunches to the children
in Russia and the Russian Federation or
something like that I don't know it's
hard to know exactly um with the Russian
oligarchy that that I mean that's what
the right wing really wants they were
freaking the [__] out this weekend when
they watched Wagner March towards Moscow
I mean they're like oh it's not a cue
it's not an it's not a coup attempt this
is what an Insurrection looks like hey
when we did our cue we didn't it didn't
seem like this when we did our coot like
they were just all over the [__] map
all over the map now I was in Mario uh
his Twitter space listening to these
[__] idiots lose their minds I
thought it was hilarious they wanted me
to speak but I'm like you know what I'm
just here to enjoy the show and you know
most time I'm in the room either
listening or as a speaker to pick up on
their narrative and pick up what they
were saying and one of the craziest
[__] stupidest narratives is the Joe
Biden planned all this that's right he
is such a political Mastermind but he's
dementia ridden and can't even tie his
own shoes or they gotta tell him where
to stand and where to walk to and they
got to give him cue cards but he's a
political Mastermind it's really [__]
stupid this is Nazi 101. if you're if
you're not aware Nazi 101
is where you say your your enemy is
strong your enemy is weak all at the
same time this the whole thing this is
to to uh DeMent the minds of your
supporters and your followers
speaking of delusion and Maga Trump's
supporter delusion did you watch the
Nazi rally over the weekend holy [__]
Chris Christie stands up on the stage in
front of a microphone a lot of the
candidates were there but Chris Christie
was one of them there at this Faith Nazi
conference or some [__] I don't know
white Christian nationalist uh rally uh
you know I don't know if the it was
officially sanctioned by the KKK but it
seemed to be ah here's the thing Chris
Christie went up in front of the
microphone and was like uh true true
truth and truth and they started to boo
him
all right now this morning the media and
and again I I don't listen to a lot of
the media in other words I don't spend a
lot of my [__] free time listening to
a bunch of half-wits give political
punditry and commentary well they don't
know what the [__] they're talking about
and what I mean by that is they don't
know really American people they don't
know and let me tell you something this
morning their takes on this [__]
Faith conference is absolute 100 [__]
garbage they are freaking out the media
is freaking out oh his polls are moving
Trump's going up in the polls oh my God
it had no effect on him the 37 Federal
no no [__] Sherlock hey hey all you
[__] talking heads on TV come listen
to my show first and I'll tell you what
the [__] is gonna happen
it's not complicated to understand he's
gonna be the nominee
I don't know what I don't know how many
times I have to say it how many times I
gotta go over it and explain to you why
he's gonna be it's really simple if you
know how Cults work you'll know that
he's gonna be the nominee
it's very simple it's very simple
I mean any realistic timeline Chris
Christie would get up in front of this
crowd start speaking truth half the
crowd would be like you know what [__]
that guy and start screaming and yelling
and hooping and hollering and cheering
on Chris Christie and the crowd would
erupt they booed him they booed him for
telling simple [__] truth
and and and the media is wondering why
this morning that Donald Trump it's it's
the DeSantis has not gained it all in
the polls he's spending mountains of
money and his campaign is collapsing and
Donald Trump seems to be at the top of
the Heap how is this possible
because it's a cult what the [__] don't
you people understand and they're voting
based on affiliation the other thing the
media is failing to recognize is that
the majority of people don't vote in
primaries it's only the [__]
extremist
and the most extreme of the extreme are
not Chris Christie supporters they're
not Mike Pence supporters they're not
gonna vote for Nikki Haley they are not
going to vote for Tim Scott or whoever
that [__] idiot is from North Dakota
they're not going to vote for meatball
they're gonna vote for Trump
by the third Tuesday of these [__]
primaries Donald Trump will walk away
with this folks he's gonna have every
[__] delegate even if he's in a
goddamn prison cell he's gonna win on
the first ballot at the at the
convention on the floor it's gonna
happen
stop acting like it's not
what the [__] is wrong with you people
know your [__] enemy and attack them
don't you know how politics works stop
concentrating on these [__] schlubs
that are running for nothing
I heard this this morning Chris Christie
he's running to be the wrecking ball no
no Chris Christie really does believe
that he can win
he's just he doesn't understand that his
party is gone
it's gone Jesus Christ one of these
[__] idiots stood in front of a
camera and Marjorie Taylor Green's boy
toy that's what you want to call him I
don't know how big the toy is on the boy
but the point is this
is that he said we need to listen to
Stalin Mao and Hitler
when we're talking about education
because when we win the minds of
children we win
Jesus Christ the moms of Liberty those
[__] Nazi [__] that's right I call
them Nazi maybe or should I what what
would be the appropriate name
so that no one gets offended Nazi [__]
Nazi [__] I don't know
yeah oh Tony you're so offensive for
calling you kidding me they printed on I
showed you this last week on their
[__] newsletter
a quote from Hitler
and they put his name on it they weren't
just like oh that's a decent quote we'll
stick that in a new they were like yeah
that's the one from Hitler that we want
that one from Hitler we'll do and we'll
do another one from Hitler next [__]
week
this is moms of Liberty who are
continuing to go across the country have
national conventions by the way but go
across the country
and absolutely trying to destroy our
public education system
so much so that they can indoctrinate
the youth because they believe if they
indoctrinate the youth
into their delusion then they win and
they will
unless you stand in their way unless we
stand in the way we the people and folks
it's not complicated it really isn't
this isn't [__] hard to understand
that this [__] ideology is not
popular just look at Rhonda santis okay
he's really [__] awkward he's really
[__] weird he's totally unlikable
right
it's he's a [__] box God damn he eats
pudding with his [__] fingers
he goes across the country he can't stop
saying the word woke
which is the tenement of their stupid
[__] delusional ideology
that somehow it's I mean somehow it's
brown black gay people trans people that
are destroying our country and they're
destroying white people it's [__]
weird they think sis is a slur on
Twitter
they think sis is a slur
we're just calling you straight dude
that's all we're doing it's just calling
you straight that's it that's all it is
besides it's just a shorter version so
we're not typing out
Jesus I started misgendering these [__]
over the weekend
that's right all these [__]
right-wing white privileged fragile men
I started misgendering them I'm gonna
keep doing it too that's right I'm gonna
do it on purpose [__] them
it's enough of this [__] it's enough of
this light-handed light gloved [__]
these people are quoting Hitler folks
they're showing up with Nazi Flags
there's Nazis punching Nazis that's how
freaked out they are
over the weekend there was proud boys
fighting what looked like Patriot front
which I don't actually think it was
Patriot front
a lot of people calling it Patriot front
and then
and then these [__] idiots think
Patriot front is feds like look look
you're not real Nazis
or Nazis get out of here you half-ass
Nazis
it's [__] wild [__] it's a wild time
to be alive but you gotta pay attention
you gotta pay attention
and one of the reasons why you gotta pay
attention is because you gotta look at
their rhetoric from Russia you gotta
look at it they were [__] terrified
now look this is a terrifying situation
in Russia I listen this is not a good
situation that we have in Russia ever
since Nicholas III was [__] murdered
with his family and the Bolsheviks took
over acting like they were Communists
but they are really [__] murderers
and then Stalin that [__] murderous
piece of [__] listen
Russia has been unstable for a long time
and the Russian Federation is is just a
sugar coating of that and it has been
since the since the fall of the Soviet
Union
teetering teetering
on the brink of collapse it seems like
over the weekend
pregosian decided that he was going to
march to Moscow to test Putin now he
claimed that it was to to get rid of the
generals in in the Russian federation's
army
okay that's what he claimed
but this he said he needed new
leadership some thought it meant the
generals of the Russian the Federation
Army some thought it meant potent Putin
thought it was Putin Putin apparently
fled and Putin to his credit did not
hardly Flinch now the problem is
pagosian and Wagner group shot down
several helicopters and fired upon
Russian troops
so that's what they're trying to sort
out and it seems like
the president of Belarus made the deal
because his country was going to fall
there was going to be a coup against him
because he is Putin's Ally
now all this is good in the short term
for Ukraine
which in the short term is good for
democracy
but there's a lot at stake here around
the world and when you have right
Wingers cheering on murderous dictators
not to be overthrown by a [__] Thug
because let's face it pagosian is no
[__] walk in the park I don't think
that the world wants progosian to have
his hands on a nuclear Arsenal and it's
unclear rather pagosian would actually
take power in Russia or if there would
be a vacuum and someone else would step
in
it's very unclear but it is clear that
the the Russian Civil War is not over
right now it's just a a war of words
they're shouting back and forth now
we'll see what becomes of it
but it's in high interest in in for us
and for our democracy and democracy in
general around the world that's the
whole point of why the Western World
stood with Ukraine and said no you can't
you can't march into a sovereign country
just because you want to
they're a democracy even even as corrupt
as Ukraine's democracy was it's worth
defending that's right any democracy
anywhere where the people the people
want democracy they strive for a better
future with democracy it's worth
fighting for every single [__] inch
and the people of Ukraine realize that
they know that that's why they fought so
hard to keep it and it does seem that
the Russian Federation is on its heels
it seems I I think there was five
thousand I think there's five thousand
that were marching towards Moscow they
got within like 100 kilometers or 200
kilometers of Moscow and they stopped
now it's unclear why rather Putin had
something over percussion whether it was
his life or his family's life and it's
unclear exactly the deal that was made
with the president of Belarus but it
seems like there could be a shitload of
money being exchanged
or the thought of a shitload of money
why they kill progression
but here's the thing
here's the thing is that the right
Wing's reaction in this country is so
important Jesus Christ they were like ow
this is all a CIA up
yeah it says but Joe Biden Joe Biden's
trying to distract from Hunter Biden
listen Hunter Biden took a plea deal
what the [__] are you people yapping
about look you can make up your stupid
[__] in your house and tell are your
house oversight committee with James
Comer and your Judiciary Committee with
Jim Jordan
and you can say all right the
Ocean Gate submarine was all made up in
distraction and then the Russian Civil
War it was a distraction but you look
stupid
you look stupid because you say that Joe
Biden isn't capable of running a country
but he's capable of making up an entire
[__] storyline behind Ocean Gate
he's in he's able he's able to to deploy
the United States government whether it
be the CIA or DOD to help pregosian in
an operation to get within 200
kilometers of Moscow and stop
you [__] kidding get the [__] out of
here No One Believes that garbage No One
Believes that they're trying to cover up
the hunter Biden lies they know their
[__] lies listen a United States
Attorney who was pointed by your [__]
orange deity
Donald Trump appointed a United States
Attorney in Delaware to put Joe Biden
and Hunter Biden in prison
and the best that he got was a couple
[__] misdemeanors on tax fraud
and he collected money that that Hunter
Biden paid back to the IRS that's the
best he got you [__] idiots really
honestly it's a shame that that Hunter
by name has to plead to these charges to
be quite honest with you you talk about
weaponization of [__] government give
me a couple misdemeanor charges with the
IRS after you've done paid your taxes
that you supposedly owe and then and
then give him a felony stupid ass gun
charge that's the worst dumb we need to
get rid of that [__] gun charge by
the way if you're if you're a 2A bro and
you believe in the Second Amendment and
your right to bear arms then it doesn't
matter if you're an addict or not
I don't give a [__] if it's
uninfringible by God it's uninfringible
when you're [__] stoned or you're
high on Coke or [__] heroin whatever
it is crack cocaine get it on [__]
it's either uninfringible or it isn't
make up your mind it's a dumb stupid
[__] charge so are the two IRS
charges that he's got after he paid his
taxes [__] I'd want my money back
oh you're in a chart I gotta plea guilty
to the the [__] I just paid [__] you
give me my money back
[__] them
that's the way I see it it's a
distraction from the hunter Biden tax
payments
get the [__] out of here with this
nonsense you think that Joe Biden and
the administration DOD and CIA went on
full operation to make it look like
there's a coup in Russia to cover the
hunter Biden store when we all know the
story we know the real story and then we
know you're stupid [__] lies like we
understand bull stories your little
made-up [__] alternate reality
and then the actual truth like we we got
both sides we and no one gives a [__]
listen if no one gives a [__] about your
[__] orange Mussolini Jesus being
charged in the state of New York and the
Manhattan dea's office with 34 [__]
felonies of business fraud then in South
Florida United States District of South
Florida with 37 [__] felonies for the
espionageant because he's stolen
harbored tot secret documents and
wouldn't give them back and then
obstructed and lied and said he did but
he didn't the [__] out of here
man
we know what your distraction is about
when you make up stupid ass [__] about
the president United States and his son
and his family we understand we get it
we know what you're trying to distract
us from
but if you're not going to if you're not
gonna reverse course and leave your cult
leader what makes you think what makes
you think
that that we're going to not support the
person the one candidate in this race
that is going to be the nominee of the
democratic party who supports democracy
who has been working for the American
people last two years what makes you
think we're not going to vote for him
just because his son is a degenerate
really and you
if we want to talk about degenerate
children by God we can talk about
Grandpa poopy pants
speaking of Grandpa poopy pants did you
see the he he needs to get new material
everyone's been wondering what the the
the the the grunting and the [__]
his pants did you see this clip oh we're
gonna watch it
we're gonna watch this more than once
it's hilarious really he's been doing
this for a while now I don't know the
exact story that he's telling or the
context of the story really he needs to
get new material
he needs to get new material is what he
needs to do
and I know he works on it down at
Mar-A-Lago when he's crashing weddings
and [__] right
I mean that's what he's doing when he
goes and crashes these weddings and he
has these stupid [__] Nazi rallies
down at Mar-A-Lago that his girlfriend
Kerry Lake excuse me excuse me his
friend Carrie Lake
I don't want to get a season assist I
last I mean we found this out last
Friday that she's apparently living
there I don't know
I mean usually when someone moves into
your house
I'm just saying so Carrie Lake that she
joins him in their little they're a
little fascist uh Nazi rallies they're
Wine Fest where they're like not like
wine like the drink like we didn't win
but we won we won by so many people
you know the wine vest that they have
they wine and [__] and moan about how
they [__] lost and they say they won
they lie that's all it is it's [__]
lies just a waterfall of lies down there
at Mar-A-Lago
but that's what he's doing is he's
working his material you know what I
mean
he's he's working on his 20 minutes his
best 20 minutes and that's in his best
20 minutes I'm not kidding you that
grunting and look like he's [__] his
pants
and now I I actually emailed and I'm not
I'm not I'm gonna be fully transparent I
emailed Stormy Daniels over the weekend
I'm trying to get stormy on the show
because honestly
I want to answer the the one question
there's a lot of questions you could ask
stormy right a lot of questions about
Trump and not even about Trump I mean I
I'd love to have a conversation with her
but the one question I do have
and when you watch this clip you'll know
what I'm talking about
is that what Howie is that his is that
the I don't know I'm just saying I don't
want to lose the audience here by
everyone dropping off because I'm
talking about Donald Trump and his
Ovation but I I'm just I'm wondering I'm
wondering I I would figure that she
might know uh once she got close to the
mushroom if that was exactly the noise
let the Cheeto dust q and honor makes
I'm just I'm just one I'm just wondering
I'm just you know because a lot of
people sounds like a shitty he's
[__] in his pants which I mean you
know yeah sometimes when you're having
trouble and you're constipated it could
sound like that but there's other things
that could possibly
sound that way I don't know
and what a Monday huh it's been a damn
long weekend with the news I mean just
tons of news and I appreciate you uh
coming back this week the big audience
today the best audience in the world
here at the Tony Michaels podcast don't
forget to subscribe here on YouTube if
you're new
you're not going to want to miss a
single show let me tell you how this
works we go live every single weekday
that's right Monday through Friday we do
not [__] around
here at the Tony Michaels podcast we
don't do a podcast once a week for an
hour or twice a week for 30 minutes Hail
to the no we do it every single day we
do it live and we do two full hours
sometimes we go three on Friday we went
three hours
and we needed time we had to get through
the material you know what I mean
actually I think there was a couple
times this week that we went more yeah
we did last Tuesday because we were we
were talking about the uh
uh the the the sub the submarine or no
maybe that was a week before [__] I
don't remember they get away from me you
know what I mean
it's just like news news news news news
and I gotta yell and scream about it
keep up and I lose track anyways two
full hours if you're new here two full
hours every single weekday Monday
through Friday on YouTube Twitter and
broadcast to Twitter even though you
know Elon hasn't figured out Periscope
yet it's still [__] over there Elon fix
Periscope man Jesus Christ you're
wanting people to broadcast live
on Twitter you want it to be the next
media space we'll fix Periscope dummy or
do something different Call Me DM me you
dumb [__]
um also you can watch us on Facebook at
the Tony Michaels if you still have a
Facebook account if you're still logging
in over there on the books of face hey
there's another YouTube channel you can
watch us on to the up bar go to the up
bar.com or just type in the up wire in
your YouTube search browser you can
follow us there you might want to follow
us there too in case I get banned I'm
I'm due for a suspension I think
right are we doing for a suspension on
YouTube I'm just checking
um so go follow us on the up bar in case
we do and then you know what even if we
get suspended on YouTube across the
board you can follow us on Twitch it's
free to follow us on Twitch go to
twitch.tv
slash the Tony Michaels don't forget we
got a ton of people who link their
Amazon Prime account to their Twitch
account you have to re-subscribe every
month we've had a lot of people not
remember that so go back in re-subscribe
here's what happens to anyone who
doesn't know if you have an Amazon Prime
account
you can link it to a Twitch account and
you get one free subscription with
Amazon gaming on your Prime account and
you can actually give us that
subscription see it's free to follow on
Twitch but it costs money to subscribe
but you get one free subscription with
Prime
so you just link your Prime account to
your Twitch account you give us that one
free subscription every single month
because you got to redo it every month
and we get a couple bucks it's literally
like two dollars and seven cents I think
I've done the math
but if you link your Prime account in
your Twitch account and if you want to
know how to do it just go to the
tonymichaels.com that's D Tony
michaels.com the link is like four down
it says link Amazon Prime to Twitch and
then you can link them it shows you the
directions our great moderator the
mighty librarian laid out these
directions for everyone it's super
simple super easy
but make sure that if you have your
Prime account linked to your church
account that you go in and you
re-subscribe
to Twitch with your Prime account just
go to the Tony michaels.com that's lead
Tony michaels.com all the links are
there
I got some clips to show you it's been a
wild weekend and we're gonna get to it
and maybe talk more about this Russian
news and we're definitely going to talk
about the Republican primary oh and I
want to tell you how obsessed how
obsessed
the right wing is with the shirtless RFK
Putin have you seen this RFK Putin
Ah that's right he did three push-ups
and he bench pressed 60 pounds four
times and they think he's a monster well
they would they would believe in that
delusion everyone don't don't don't go
anywhere we're gonna go through all this
and more when we come back right after
this break we'll be right back don't
don't touch that dial as they say in
radio
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
trying to remember all the things you've
boycotted can really get you stressed
because there's no good way to keep them
from becoming a cluttered mess well now
there's boycott binder the ingenious
organizer that keeps track of everything
and everyone you've ever boycotted the
72 category filing system makes it easy
to organize boycotted people places and
things so you can find them with ease
the large centered area can even fit
your boycott sign but best of all when
you're done the boycott binder folds
right up so you can take it anywhere so
if you're tired of having a cluttered
mess call now and get the boycott binder
for just 29.99 plus you'll also receive
our next rep as a bonus just Loop it
around your neck to travel with ease but
call right now and we'll double the
offer that's two boycott binders and two
neck straps for just 29.99 boycott
binders brought to you by the same
makers of binders full of women
bumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
hey
we're near the top of the hour we're
gonna get started We're not gonna waste
a lot of time at least one of your time
we're gonna get right to it
uh did you see the um the clip of Nazis
punching Nazis this is um honestly this
is one of the best best Clips I saw on a
weekend how could you not like that
when Nazis are punching Nazis I mean
that's that's a wild time to be alive
but I you know I I'm not opposed to
punching Nazis our Nazis getting punched
for that matter but let me tell you
something when Nazis are punching other
Nazis
oh baby you know we are doing something
right when that happens right now here's
the story
so we've we've shown several videos here
and mocked
um Patriot front we had we actually had
uh Joe from DC here on on to where he
was mocking Patriot from remember when
he's yelling from his red bike he's
calling him Mama's Boys and all that
so Patriot front is a bunch of sissies
that um they cosplay with plastic
Shields and underwear is face masks well
I mean that's what it looks like at
least and they tried a half-ass match
with khakis and blue shirts now they're
overt Nazis they're white supremacists
they're fascist and they don't make many
bones about it right it's really bad
though for the right wing in the
Republican Party the pro-life movement
the anti-woman movement the anti-lgbt
movement to be associated with people
who are so overtly fascist right
they they might they like their fascism
still thin veiled to some degree right
with the hate groups like moms of
Liberty or proud boys okay it's what
they they prefer or the Republican party
in general
in general that's right if you got an R
next to your name
you're a Nazi that's what it is at this
point what do you want from me don't
[__] don't be saying Tony that's
outrageous I don't want to tell you
that's their fault not mine I'm just
[__] telling you what I'm just
calling the balls and Strikes okay
when you're when your ideology and your
entire National platform
is on par with people who carry
swastikas on their Flags in front of
Disney in a drank shows you're a Nazi
sad [__] works man then you may not
think you're a Nazi
but the Nazis think you're [__] Nazis
hmm it's kind of a problem and then you
have the moms of Liberty quoting Hitler
and then over the weekend at this Faith
conference they're like yeah Hitler he
knew about education that's what we need
to do as conservatives Nazis
but I digress so over the weekend we had
we had what appeared to be Patriot front
I actually do not think this is Patriot
front
uh to be honest it doesn't look like
Patriot front to me it looks like a
group that is cosplaying to beat Patriot
front which is even more pathetic okay
they get into a little spat with the
proud boys okay who are also white
supremacists I don't give a [__] who
their leader is they're white
supremacists they're white nationalists
they're [__] Nazis they're fascist
they're Nazis okay and again they might
not think they're Nazis but the Nazis
think they're Nazis so
what am I supposed to do what do you
want from me
I mean I I can't I can't go to the Nazis
and be like look okay I know that they
hold your ideology and I know they hold
your beliefs and I know you you're the
tenements of of what you believe in your
your National platform are essentially
the same but look these proud boys are
kind of like Nazi life you're Nazi Nazi
they're Nazi what do you want me to do I
can't go [__] negotiate a deal who's
more Nazi come on
hmm anyways so this half-assed Patriot
front Group which is really kind of
funny that I actually have to say this
half-assed page because Patriot front is
pretty half-assed
I mean these are the [__] these are
the little in cells that that made up
plastic Shields they got they got they
wear masks so that you can't dox them
ever since Charlottesville they learned
oh man if we're gonna be Nazis we better
cover our faces because the internet's
gonna identify us now that's going to be
very important here in just a minute
when you when you follow what I'm saying
so the proud Boys in this uh um Patriot
front light group I guess I don't know I
don't know what maybe it's Patriot
behind group instead of front they're
behind I don't know what the [__] their
name is
I don't know anyways they're getting a
little spat right
and the proud boys appear to be a little
tougher than the Patriot behind group
that's what I'm going to call them
Patriot behind
[__] I don't know
if you watch them Pat each other down in
the woods front or behind you might ask
that question to them
just saying I I mean I don't give a [__]
they got nothing to do with me man
that's their business I encourage it hey
whatever you want to do folks if you
want to go Pat each other down and be in
front or behind each other in the woods
as long as it's consensual and you're
adults it's good enough for me do what
you want have a great time I don't care
but they get into a little spat in The
Patriot front or the the proud boys are
beating the [__] out of the Patriot
behind group
so much so that they pull their mask off
right I'm gonna show you the video let
me show you the video here this is
fantastic they're fighting the other
thing too that you notice in this video
they get [__] they get they get
flashbacks from the Insurrection because
these proud boys man they get their
[__] American flags and they're
really beating people I don't know what
it is they love the [__] they're so
patriotic they love to take the American
flag and [__] beat someone up with it
the greatest part is Patriot all right
proud boys are like yeah you're the
you're the racist I mean we're we're
racing but you're you're you're more
racist but you're not you're not as Nazi
as us but you're not real so you're not
real Nazi we're the real Nazis you're
you're feds
and that's a word you're going to hear
and that's a word you're going to see
online is feds they think there's
Patriot fruit Patriot fruit hey that's a
good one it was a slip but that's great
that's great see I walk into these
things every once in a while the Patriot
fruit
oh man
someone's gonna start trying to cancel
me for being homophobic the Patriot
fruit group
um
they
they decide that they don't want to be
doxxed right so they don't want to they
don't want to be docs they don't want
their Mass taken off but when their
masks are taken off their faces are
revealed
and they got them on camera now what
happens is is that people think they're
federal agents now when you see these
people who get their masks taken off
you're gonna realize these are not
federal agents okay and and the one
reason why you're gonna realize they're
not federal agents is because generally
speaking the feds don't have 19 year old
boys as undercover Federal officers
inside of a white supremacy group okay
that's just not normally what the feds
do
and these are 19 20 year old boys
they're not men they're boys and I think
the two that had their mask off have
actually been confirmed uh being former
members or people who piled around with
the Patriot front group
now now the right wing is accusing them
of being someone totally different
and they're saying oh they're antifa
feds
well I mean
the feds are generally antifa meaning
they're anti-fascists the feds usually
keep an eye on fascists and Nazis it's
usually what the feds do that's why all
the fascist nazi groups like The
Republican party want to defund the FBI
the feds but here is the video
uh the proud boys and the Patriot fruit
um that's what we're going to call them
for for right now until I learned their
actual name of this uh half-assed group
of the Patriot front
but um Patriot fruit and proud boys here
are fighting and uh I'm telling you it's
[__] delicious uh take a take a look
[Music]
get out of here
oh my god [__]
and you hear a lot of different stuff in
there right you hear the f word thrown
around be gone [__] some of them are
like don't cuss at them don't cuss at
them like why not
I mean now again I'm not a proud boy fan
but hey what what am I not supposed to
cheer on
am I not supposed to cheer on these two
groups fighting each other that's
exactly what we want I've been telling
you this for a long time
I'm telling us for a long time we have
to draw wedges because the right Wingers
are really easy to draw wedges right
they're really into power and they're
really into consolidating power that
that's that's what we've seen in Russia
over the weekend right
they're really into consolidating Power
that's their entire [__] Focus their
focus is not like oh what do the people
want you know they voted for this the
constituency generally likes this the
population wants to have this this and
this that I don't give a [__] about that
they care about their own Consolidated
power right and right Wingers in general
believe this that's why it's so easy to
drive wedges down in between them
is because one wants power the other one
wants power and then when this one gets
power out they can't have it we want it
back right so they [__] fight each
other Neo-Nazi groups for for decades
and decades and decades in this country
have have fought each other more than
they did than they've fought and for
their white supremacy to be quite honest
and it's only because when you get into
these right-wing ideologies they they
only are concerning themselves with
their own [__] power that's the
problem with the Republicans that's the
problem they have they've gone so far
extreme to the right that they can't
focus on anything but their own power
nothing absolutely nothing can you
imagine if there was a [__]
Republican in charge when that [__]
bridge in Pennsylvania collapsed on I-95
they'd still be standing around figuring
out who's gonna take credit when it's
done a year from now
yeah that's what I'm [__] said they'd
be standing around arguing
right Wingers would be standing around
arguing
trying to figure out a year from now
when we open up I-95 for traffic again
who's gonna take credit
all the while Democrats just like hey
how about we just [__] do it and then
you know we can find over who's [__]
fault it is and who who cleaned up the
mess afterwards right
that's why Democrats typically run big
cities metropolitan areas the reason why
people generally vote for Democrats in
those [__] areas is cause [__] has to
get done we can't people can't stand
around waiting for a bunch of
Republicans figuring out who's going to
have more power when the crisis is over
like just deal with it do your [__]
job that's what we want so that's why
generally in big big cities because
there's a lot of things there's a lot of
infrastructure big cities there's
highways sidewalks Parks water sewer
Electric
internet all these things are important
to big cities they don't want you don't
want Republicans in charge of that [__]
I mean look at Texas Texas is charging
their own [__] power grid how'd that
work out for you down there with a bunch
of [__] Republicans in charge of that
[__] every goddamn winner they're
worried and then every summer they're
[__] worried about this [__]
because they can't Republicans don't
govern
they suck at it and the reason why they
suck at it is exactly this fascist
absolutely Fallen to this vacuum of
power watch
[Music]
I want to mention that the proud boys
are really that not that intimidating
right I mean we're going to get to the
part where they're kind of punching each
other and throwing punches here
the proud boys are a bunch of [__]
let's face it they're just loud they're
loud they they and they they wear
American flags on their hats and they
carry American flags as Weapons right
we're really supposed to believe that
you're a threat come on man are you
serious
are you serious
I mean yeah yeah your idea is leaking
into the mainstream public that's
dangerous [__]
but you as a group me a [__] break
you can't you can't get rid of five
little teenagers because that's what
these kids are
this Patriot fruit group they're like 19
20 year old kids they're practically
just out of high school barely out of
college yet
and grown-ass men like the proud boys
can't get rid of five of them I think
that's how many there is in this video
give me a [__] break come on and
we're supposed to stand around
pretending the proud boys are some kind
of
[__] forced to be reckoned with get
the [__] out of here man listen where I
come from these proud boys guys would
get their [__] asses kicked before
they open their mouths trust me
[__] out of here with this nonsense
they're tough guys you can't get rid of
a couple teenagers with with [__]
motorcycle mask on come on man
here's the racist part they're like oh
you're racist and then they fling around
the f word
I I flicking around homophobic slurs
like come on man the reason why they're
doing this because they know they're on
camera at this point
I think I count five of them right the
fruit group
right I think that's I think that's what
I'm counting is five of them
the Patriot fruit group whatever they're
called I don't know what they're called
I don't know this is some kind of local
Patriot fruit chapter
um
uh I'm getting I'm getting some messages
from the chat here it says uh Patriot
farce Patriot [__] I don't know
I know what they are I have no idea
um digital waterfall here says the
fruity five I don't know listen I listen
I I don't care if you if you it doesn't
matter who you love really honestly guys
I don't give a [__] you love what you
want to love and what I'm against is
that you tell other people what they can
and can't do while you're doing that
thing that you're telling they can't do
that's what I'm against leap
[__] alone that's all I want
you to do let people be people but let
love be love that's all I want and a
bunch of Nazis like the proud boys and
the Patriot fruit group or the Patriot
front group whichever one it is
I don't give a damn I don't care if it's
Rhonda santis or Donald Trump or anyone
else disparaging the lgbtq community
especially using transgenderism to try
to [__] take away consent from
parents and take away our rights to walk
around like we want to do you want to
dress how you want to dress who gives a
[__] you want to wear a dress wear a
dress if you want to transition
transition that's your life that's your
Liberty this is a free [__] country
you do what you want
you do what you want here is uh here's
here's the end of here it's getting
gonna get kind of Juicy here because
here's where they start throwing punches
and throwing Flags go go get the [__]
out of here dude we're not here
and if isn't it funny though it's funny
how some of these uh the proud boys look
like this uh fruity five as digital
waterfall says you know what I mean they
they look like them because they they
got their mask on they're trying to hide
their identities you know because they
got jobs they can't be outed as white
supremacists as members of The Proud
boys but watch as they get heated here
when they rip the mask off of these five
little these five little teenagers here
whatever I think they're about 19 20
years old you'll see when they take the
mask off [__]
there you go now it's getting heated
there's Nazis punching Nazis
[Music]
oh my God
so that's where it gets heated now again
you're gonna see um you're gonna see
here and they're gonna this camera guy
is gonna get closer in uh because
they're ripping the mask off and once
they once they discover oh yeah we can
rip their mask off
because they hadn't said this until they
started taking their mask off that these
guys are feds these guys are feds right
and the reason why
um they do this is for theatrics for for
the for cat turd and Jack prostate and
DC Drano and the rest of the [__]
idiots on Twitter
D mask them so here's this one kid
standing here
you can't look ah come on he's not that
[__] old and you're gonna see the
other guy now there's a security guard
standing here trying to break this up
[Applause]
ask him damask him he says
do not dox people you hear that do not
dox people see these people are really
[__] torn right they're really torn
in this
um um uh DK Hall says here uh it's like
a rival biker ganks well sorta sorta but
more like from their mom's basements you
know usually biker gangs don't live
in their mother's basements
what are you saying or their Grandma's
house a lot of these a lot of these
[__] proud boys you know these gangs
are in their 50s right they they used to
want to be in a motorcycle gang and they
never were and they're just [__]
racist and bigots
and they go they go take steroids and
pump some iron like RFK Jr and they
think they're big stuff and then they go
get into a little bra with a bunch of
teenagers from Patriot fruit group
I don't know let's let's watch here as
they rip more mask off of these uh
Patriot fruit group to try to dox them
because some people saying hey don't
knock some and then some are like yeah
they're feds uh they can't decide
demons
okay so there you take see this guy now
this guy's been misidentified and you
see this proud boy here our proud
grandpa it's not a boy really right he
calls himself a brown proud boy but it's
like proud papa right you're not a proud
boy I mean this guy this guy here right
here the one that just got his mask off
he's covering his face see they didn't
want to cover his face because they got
jobs and [__] you know what I mean
um they don't want to be outed as a
[__] Nazi so he covers his face
um but he's a boy he's a boy now watch
here
there's another boy see and he's trying
to cover his face right
now on the internet these [__] people
went crazy they were like oh these are
feds these are feds I'm like dude feds
are not 19 man
the feds are not gonna send in the 19
year old
as an agent undercover agent in a
Neo-Nazi group they're like oh it's a
false flag that's not how it works that
that is not that is not how the
undercover work of the FBI works okay
it's not how they work they don't do it
that way they don't
they infiltrate groups is what they do
that's what they do that's the actual
work of law enforcement and undercover
agents dummies
it's really stupid [__] but you can't
explain this to these people these
people are delusional they think Donald
Trump is smart let's let's watch let's
finish watching is these little
these little uh Patriot kids whatever
they are and kind of cover their faces
because they don't want to get doxed and
they're running away
this
yes
and they even say the name of the guy
did you hear it Casey they know who this
is they know they are they know they're
not [__] feds they know who these
people are
they know they're not [__] feds it's
ridiculous
[Laughter]
um Nazi ninjas is that is that what
we're calling them Nazi ninjas they do
look like they got [__] Halloween
costumes on don't they oh my God so
here's this last shot here
um yeah Casey Casey used to be a proud
boy see he used to be a proud boy so
they know who he is right and he
defected to go and start a group
called the Nazi ninjas or the the the
fruity five I don't know what the [__]
this is actually there's six of them it
looks like one two three four five C six
I see six so they're not the fruity five
anymore there's a seditious six maybe I
don't know what the [__] you want from
me on this it's Nazis punching Nazis how
could I not show this on the show
[Laughter]
oh [__] speaking of Nazis
holy [__] did you see this clip
I I don't even know I don't even know
how to how to explain this
this clip is uh of Liberty University do
you know Liberty University they did a
Netflix uh documentary on this uh Jerry
Falwell and Jerry Falwell Jr Jr is the
one him and his wife would had
sexcapades with a young man right
where he would cuck he would sit in the
corner and [__] and watch a young man
have sex with a wife which is nothing
wrong with that hey if you're gonna do
that whatever whatever you want to do
whatever floats your boat Jerry Falwell
Jr I I am and whatever she wants to do
really hey if you listen I'm not gonna
disparage you it's just that the fact
that you're gonna tell other people what
to do
and not to do when you're doing it no
[__] out of here
but this uh this this a clip that you're
about to see is
um a member of the Liberty University
he's he's some some I don't know and his
name is Ryan
heffelfin been hellfinbin I don't know
helferman
uh Ryan here was at the faith and
freedom Nazi rally they called it the
free faith and freedom Coalition Gala
but it's actually the the Nancy rally
and he proves it by his statement here
now we watched as moms of Liberty
last week decided it was a good idea to
quote Hitler in their newsletter
not only quote Hitler like put the quote
from Hitler they were like yeah we're
gonna give him [__] credit
whoo
I did not see that coming holy [__]
um but this little interview with uh
Marjorie Taylor Green's uh boy toy you
know what I'm talking about what's his
name what's this hey what what's
marjorie's new boy toys name I don't
know how
big the toy is on the boy you know it's
hard to tell sometimes with these idiots
but this was in Washington D.C at the
Nazi Faith rally you know they're really
faithful to Nazis oh listen to listen to
Ryan here you'll you'll find out he
really likes the ideas and teachings of
Stalin Mao and especially Hitler holy
agree with that basically this is an
Evangelistic movement on the left and
that's what's happening it's
indoctrination I mean they're
proselytizing to the Next Generation and
what we're discovering is parents and
conservatives is wait a second okay if
you follow that you've all that the left
is indoctrinating children so what we
want to do is indoctrinate them because
that's what Hitler says I'm not [__]
you I'm not kidding you any they call
themselves conservatives they're not
[__] Services they're Nazis but
listen education really is evangelism so
if you don't control education you
cannot control the future and and Stalin
knew that Mal knew that right Hitler
knew that we have to get that back for
conservative values
um
as Gabe Sanchez say what was that I'm
sure he's going to do one on this uh
what what wait a second what what'd you
say did you say did you say we need to
get back to the teachings of
of the mustache man is that what you
said well let's listen again see what um
uh the guy who loves 1930s Germany says
here let's listen to that again and some
conservatives is wait a second education
really is evangelism no it's not no it's
not but go ahead let's hear it again so
if you don't control education you
cannot control the future and and Stalin
knew that Mal knew that right Hitler
knew that we have to get that back for
conservative values
whoosh
whoosh so there you have it there you
have if you're wondering why they're in
States
um Banning books if you're wondering why
they're banning curriculum if you're
wondering why they're they're they don't
want people to learn Real History they
want them to learn their little white
and Christian nationalist re revised
whitewashed history if you're wondering
what that is
this is what it is they're saying the
quiet part out loud folks
I think you probably should [__]
listen right and the reason why is
because
one of the groups doing this
is the moms of Liberty here it is again
here it is again
this is their newsletter June 2023
. here's the quote that they have at the
top of the [__] they didn't bury the
quote
and they accredited Adolf Hitler
and here here is a is a person from The
Liberty University saying yes we want to
we want to learn from Hitler and we want
to indoctrinate by using education as
evangelism and make sure that our
Christian National Christian bat
nationalist Christian values
pollute the minds of children and they
and the moms of Liberty is an arm of
this Nazi push in this country if you
don't believe it's a Nazi push you're
not [__] paying attention you're not
paying attention
quote here he alone who owns the youth
gains the future Adolf Hitler Abe
Sanchez
glad you're joining us at this point
um I hear you're talking about are you
you talking about Portland well I was
talking about punching Nazis punching
Nazis which led me to the Nazi rally
they had in DC with the the freedom
Faith Coalition which led me to moms of
Liberty which led me to the other Nazi
the guy from Liberty University they use
Liberty a lot right they're like you
know what well we gotta hide our fascism
we gotta hide our fascism so what's the
opposite what's the opposite of
Oppression we'll use that word yeah yeah
well it's always freedom and liberty and
justice right and then when those things
you know they're like oh no no that's
not Justice you know that's the
weaponization of the Justice that's this
and it's every single point they always
complain whether it's the guy that's in
DC or it's the you know the hilarious
situation I find it hilarious the
Portland Nazi situation
is that the proud Boys in this Patriot
fruit group they're not actually Patriot
front right so so how so because I know
you've done some research because I know
you're probably gonna do it what was
that yeah yeah and I also talked about
it yesterday on my uh my weekend Roundup
yeah good but basically the story is
it's personal beef like it's drama
they say Casey in one he used to be a
proud boy right he used to be a proud
boy and then he started this other one
that was called The Rose uh Rose
celebrity freedoms
Rose City nationalists so he they
even called it we're like ah Nazi like
we're nationalist okay yeah we're not
we're yeah you know not the ish yeah not
seeing nationalist it's close enough
they're like that way I don't have to
remember but yeah he used to be a proud
boy right and then he veered off and
started this Rose uh this this Rose City
Nationals okay this Portland group and
is there a place important because I'm
not familiar is there a place there
called Rose City is it like a uh I don't
know exactly but remember something I
mean I'm just you know where are you a
pool Rose City out of your ass right I
mean like I know the Rose Bowl which is
right too far from where I am but uh
yeah it's a city Rose City
uh it's probably a white suburb isn't it
with a lot of culsa sacks and [__] City
let's see 100 I'm probably on to
something here Rose City Park in
Portland Oregon yep see there you go so
anyway
this whole thing comes out of [__]
personal drama beef is is the way that
this all just kind of sprung up right
and so it's also funny because the
confusion from what I gathered yesterday
is that the confusion was that some of
these guys
could be a trifecta one is they're like
oh it's personal beef two it's that they
thought that these guys dressed in all
black were actually antifa and uh and
and the third one was I'm trying to
remember what the third was um but
basically
so people putting out in the chat I just
want to make sure people reporting on
here in the chat that Portland is called
Rose City it's what it's nicknames yeah
that's what his nickname I did not know
that I didn't know I just I thought it
was just like keep Keep Portland Weird
man you know whenever I go there I don't
I either called Portland OR PDX but I've
I've never called A Rose City before
anyway that's anything to know but yeah
this whole thing is so dumb but also
amazing oh because God yes everyone
can't can't accept the fact that their
attack you know again this goes back to
this whole Patriot front proud boys you
know neo-nazis they're like you guys are
feds and they're like no we're not
you're no you're back we're not seasons
and these guys like no you're not Nazis
you [__] feds right you're not with
the real Nazis we're the real not right
it's not like that Meme or Spider-Man's
pointing at right each other and like
they're fed no you're a Fed yeah no
you're a Nazi no you're no I'm the real
Nazi someone should totally maybe I'll
do it we'll see uh I've got an idea for
it anyway
um okay so the fight broke out and
they're all trying to figure out who
they are they're they're they say do you
mask
we just watched the clip yeah when they
start to fight right so they start to
throw hands yeah and at one point one of
The Proud boys grabs the one guy by the
head and his mask comes off and I think
it's Casey is the guy and I think
they're trying to show that it's Casey
because he used to be a proud boy now
he's he's a Defector he's a Nazi
Defector and he started because they
weren't Nazi enough right he had to
start his own Nazi group this is like
Rose City Putin uh uh pogrogia right
that's what this is right we got
purgosia who is now The Defector which
is Casey and we got we got the proud
boys which is the Russian Federation
right and they're fighting they're
fighting there's gonna be some throwing
them hands but they kind of stop because
then they get to this point we're like
oh we can dox them but one of The Proud
boys like no don't dox anyone right yeah
he's like don't don't
right so yeah there it's a whole thing
of these people that are like oh you
know all these guys are wearing [__]
masks they're all they're all uh they're
all fans these guys are feds they're the
feds and you got Margie Taylor agreement
like these guys are feds I 100 agree and
then you got Elon Musk everyone
yeah and Elon Musk is like who were the
unmasked individuals um I don't know
probably pretty big users of your
[__] platform right probably probably
19 year old insils yeah is what it looks
like so proud and I just want to point
out that these people are so proud and
so [__]
oh just like they just can't get enough
of the fact that they are Nazis that
they have to
You Know cover their face right well you
know the other thing too is they'll
never they'll never wear a mask for Kobe
so what they did online on Twitter
instead of finding the real identities
of these [__] [__] boxes because they
they don't want to do that because if
they find the real identity of these
[__] boxes then their whole fed thing is
smashed up right so what they did is
they found some [__] guy who looks
like one of these these little kids that
had their masks taken off who is who it
goes to school for poly SCI right and
they're like see he's a fed he's
studying political science so he's
becoming a fed and they blame this kid
who it was not is not as is not this guy
right he's not this guy he's someone
completely different but he's like
they're like yeah he's he's um he's
stunning political science so when you
study political science everyone knows
you're a Fed like what the [__] are you
talking about does that mean that
everyone else else that's a lawmaker on
Capitol Hill who studied political
science went to a liberal arts school
you know keep that in mind liberal arts
okay and studied history or political
science or whatever might be are those
people feds well anyone who ever studied
political science ever in the history
ever is a hundred percent of fed and
they will believe that because cat turd
I'm not kidding you cat turd tells them
this yeah and Elon [__] retweets cat
turd to tell them this that this is
[__] ridiculous
um but this is the world we live in I
mean over the weekend man these [__]
weirdos were obsessed
obsessed that roid raging RFK Jr can
bench press a hundred pounds six times
man they kept circulating this video and
circulating this video let me show it to
you here this is [__]
uh this is this is great okay for any of
you who don't know
that's I I guarantee that's how RFK Jr
when he's lived
[Laughter]
it's a [__] [__] toad
[__] Jabba the Hutt
[Music]
so RFK Jr for those you don't know Bobby
is um he's like 70. Bobby Bobby's like
70 right now yeah 69 Tony oh okay people
are like oh my God
they're [__] cream in her pants I
dude they're I they were jerking off all
weekend over this guy bench pressing
them
I wish you know what we need to do we
need to have the Trump clip on hand just
I'm gonna come just that one just yeah
just that little bit so we can press it
anytime I'm gonna come now
oh my God I just thought of something
about
about putting the RFK video
let me ask you let me ask you do you
even lift bro do you even live
here do you even limp bro yeah it's
funny about this I I almost bet that Joe
Biden can bench press more than [__]
RFK Jr I almost bet he can here's the
thing and I don't know if a lot of
people also I want to know I want to
know how much he can lift when he's
[__] cycled off of steroids well
right well you know he could probably
actually bench more when he's cycled off
because here's the thing a lot of people
don't know when they look at RFK 70
years old looking like this he is
[__] roided to the max I don't know
if he's I don't know I don't all he's
taken but he's taking HTH he's got to be
he's got to be taking tests because
there's another video of him out there
doing push-ups the guy barely gets
through six [__] push-ups now RFK is
not small like oh what is he like six
one six two he's not tiny you know he's
not like I just wanna I just want to
point something out real quick okay the
dude is not afraid of needles okay so he
goes anti-vaxx right I remember that at
his birthday party they made people in
2021 be vaccinated okay that's number
one number two is did you know in 1984
he got busted for heroin
Tony how do you take care listen how do
you take care Tony I am not opposed how
do you take steroids honey deciding that
they're gonna take heroin I know
whatever you want whatever you want to
do the dude's not afraid of needles
that's all I'm saying
he's not afraid of putting [__] but he
doesn't know what it is in his body
either
exactly but he does seem to be he does
seem to be mad uh to spread lies needles
I don't know why he's [__] He's
dissing The jab you know right but
here's the thing
is if you know anything about
bodybuilding or weightlifting or
strength training you know there's a
couple different things that factor in
with bodybuilding and weightlifting okay
there is bodybuilding which is achieved
through uh hypertrophy which is the is
the stress of the muscle
um in a certain way
that now your body recovers and makes
the muscle grow yeah you're making micro
tears right the recovery is key here
okay and the reason why RFK Jr looks
like this is because the Dude can't lift
a lot but you don't to achieve
hypertrophy you don't need to lift a lot
you don't need to lift heavy weight you
just have to we lift the heaviest weight
that you can lift and big muscles don't
mean strong muscles it just means a lot
of [__] recovery a lot of hypertrophy
right it's where you damage the muscle
tissue you take time to recover take
roids in HGH
and then your muscle gets bigger right
now to achieve this if you do it
naturally it takes a long time and the
reason why is because you have to lift
in a certain way and then you have to
recover for like three or four days yeah
now bodybuilders who are on gear as they
call it are roids or HGH or whatever
their F whatever [__] cycle they're
taking yeah they take those Cycles to
reduce their recovery time now what you
do is you reduce your recovery time so
you can lift again and Achieve
hypertrophy again and what you do is you
build your body bodybuilding faster when
you're on roids right right now there's
pretty much there's there's a lot of
science to this a lot of science goes
into it because there's a lot of whoa
so yeah I know it's the enemy here it's
the enemy it's the enemy but here's the
thing like when you watch Marvel movies
okay and you see like uh Chris Hemsworth
for example or Chris Evans or Chris
Brett the Chris's the Chris's those guys
now there's a lot of controversy rather
on gear or not they are on gear okay but
they are on gear okay
for a short period of time because
they're getting ready for a movie role
just to look a certain way
and then they get off the gear the
problem is with RFK Bobby is continually
on the gear yeah like he's gotta he's
gotta keep going to look this way so I
honestly want to point something out so
like
as an so naturally over time right as
men our testosterone will lower okay as
we get older it lowers and testosterone
is linked to a lot of things cognitive
function right muscle development uh
recovery time just basic
um basic ways that we function as a
human right men and women both have
testosterone
and men can take testosterone they'll go
in for like an annual shot as a booster
will say to kind of bump the levels back
up so they don't deplete you because you
know a lot of things can happen like you
can be depressed there's a lot of things
that can happen if you have low
testosterone uh now that's not taken
away from those people those people do
it as like a like a like a maintenance
kind of like all right I take it every
year I go to my doctor boom boom I get a
shot we're good to go and that's what
they do
and what RFK Jr is doing and is it's for
um
the like there's a way to do it and
there's a wrong way to do it and the way
that I feel like he's doing it is he's
like a casual be like oh yeah let me
take this [__] trt and he like
injects himself and then maybe lifts and
then doesn't do anything for a while and
then takes some more trt and then he
lifts and then doesn't do it anymore and
someone's saying someone's saying in the
chat that uh and I gotta find it back
that it's probably just trt I actually
think he's taking HGH too
um and because let me show you the clip
here now again you're gonna see RFK oh
look look at his here like a good a good
way to compare it and I'll look it up
while you're playing the Clippers if we
got to look at what his face was like
because because your your face will
change in its appearance based on what
you're taking right if you're taking
[__] human growth hormone shit's
gonna [__] is Gonna Change like some
people like if you look at if you look
at Camille nanjiani right comedian
was always kind of overweight right and
then he got skinny fat skinny fats and
now he's [__] like got this like
jawline that's crazy his face has kind
of changed a little bit you know you see
it when people are really on it your
body changes so I would be cool yeah
cause you're pumping [__] into you right
but I would be I'll I'll look it up you
may not know what it is you may not know
what it is but here here is uh RFK bench
pressing what appears to be about like a
hundred pounds right this bar is
probably four it's about 45 so I can
tell you what why no but the bar the bar
is like 45 pounds 55 pounds yeah Olympic
Bar is 45 then those look like 25 plates
and those are like 10 plates so that's
35 on each side that's seven yeah 110
pounds 115 at the max yeah 115 115. yeah
it's a 115. holy [__] man
hey come on and that's just an incline
press that's like right now this is
right he's had an incline press here and
the other thing too is he's got a
spotter okay he's got a spot you gotta
have a spotter man when you're doing
115. well that that is true now the
other thing too is you would expect that
if uh Bobby here is really strong like
all these [__] jerk offs who were
jerking off to this video this weekend I
mean they were like yeah I want my
president to have muscles that he used
to needle on a jab to get what okay all
right that seems uh reverse of what you
guys were saying last week but watch
this
get it set because uh you need that make
sure okay one there we go two that yeah
that's it three okay four there we go
five oh man he got one more he's got one
more in him one more in the tank one
more in the tank
I got seven
you got seven there is that seven let's
see if he gets eight
man
[Applause]
listen most of the Patriot front guys
those weak bastards they could do 115 at
least 18 times probably right and here
here is Bobby who's supposed to be a
physical specimen which at 70 years old
if you look like this dude you're on
gear I don't care what the [__] you're
telling me I don't care what the [__]
you say you're on gear yeah man you're
on some sort of gear and you're doing
blood tests and you're taking gear and
you're seeing what your levels are all
the [__] time I mean look the way it
is look I just I'm sending you this uh
this click the second link I sent you oh
tell me I have never seen this photo
before in my life but tell me the thing
I was just doing
for the last 15 minutes is not the exact
same uh face that he was making
[Laughter]
oh
my God
that's honestly what it is right there
it's pretty accurate yeah the other
thing the other thing that you have to
remember uh here is
um that Bobby Kennedy is [__] Rich
okay he's a Kennedy right he's got all
the money in the [__] remember he's a
Kennedy in name only right well his
family hates him I'm gonna show you a
clip about that here in a second
um but they're all [__] jerking off
to this guy over the weekend pretty
pretty weird man it's it's kind of it's
like hey look look no judgment okay
if you are in tearless men
that's cool but don't go after that
community
for the very thing that you guys are
[__] oh god oh give me that give me
that uh uh RFK Junior
I'm I'm gonna come
God damn it all right we're gonna play
that video you need to get that video
okay so here's a meme that uh Laura
Loomer put out this [__] stupid ass
she says 2024 Democratic party
presidential candidates and I said yeah
the difference here Joe Biden supports
the military supports the military and
RFK Jr is ruining with his boyfriend I
mean I'm I'm just making assumptions
here I mean maybe I'm off my rocker but
hey which one do you want right now I
want to show you another another uh
something here from the guy that RFK
wanted to debate you remember this
you remember this yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah RFK really wanted to be
debate doctor to beat me bro
I could [__] 115. it reps one set what
yeah dude and you look like that and
you're telling me you're not you're 70
you're not on roids get the [__] out of
here man okay here's Dr hotez he says uh
because they're like oh who looks
healthier RFK Junior at 69 our hotel is
at 65. makes you think I don't know what
it makes you think really
um dude I'm telling you man RFK Jr I
said it last week RFK Jr looks like he's
a [__] heavy mouth breeder when he
eats yeah he's like
that's that picture it's that picture
that's the reason why okay so Dr Hotes
who who RFK desperately wants to debate
so Hotes can kick his ass in the debate
uh basically watch him up watch this
person and Bobby up in the traffic he
refers to him as Bobby here
and I think the reason why Hotes refers
to him as Bobby is because he's a
[__] child well because no I actually
believe that it's hotels and RFK Bobby
know each other and the reason why is
because Bobby was probably in support
um because you know there's this whole
oh he needs to be the Democratic
candidate [__] this guy is a [__]
right-winger the only the only [__]
part of his policy that it will appeal
to the left is his is his uh uh views on
climate change that's why they're
running him in the Democratic primary is
to trick leftists to trick climate
activists then oh we can just lay all
the other right-wing Nazi [__] aside all
the disinformation all the shitty things
about gay frogs all the shitty things
about the vaccine will kill you and [__]
lay all that aside he believes in
climate change will vote for him that's
what they believe that's what they
believe that's their play here but
Professor um Hotes Dr Hotes here says
not sure I get the logic here I make
low-cost patent-free vaccines to help
people in low-income countries achieve
Equitable access to immunizations no
aspirations
no aspiration
to become an American version of a
shirtless Putin on a horse
someone should remind Bobby to wear
sunscreen
ah doctor Hotes is like look okay I get
it I'm a scientist I make sure
immunizations are available all around
the world patent free and I yeah because
they're patent free I don't make
gazillions of dollars like Bobby heads
over here okay that him and his family
have been able to amass a fortune over
right over [__] decades and lifetimes
and generations I don't think maybe do
you think maybe I mean it would be funny
if Dr Hotes was like oh look I'm also
working on a uh a very inexpensive
sunscreen uh if you that it'll be
available at [__] Muscle Beach
because I think that where where RFK Jr
he was in Santa Monica
and at Muscle Beach which is where
Arnold used to train and stuff right
this this is the they call it the the
bodybuilding Mecca yeah of the world is
what they call it I actually think
there's a [__] sign there yeah it
might be I mean it's gold Gold Gym is
right there and that's what it does yeah
all of famous bodybuilders uh Mike
mentzer Arnold
um they've all they've all trained there
all worked out there uh Platts I mean
Arnold still goes by it outside right
well yeah yeah yeah yeah I think he
still works out there even though he's
got his home gym and stuff yeah because
he likes to go he likes to go to the gym
in California I don't do a good Arnold
I'm sorry no no that was not good I did
watch yeah I did watching you [__] you I
did watch it I did Arnold doc yeah I did
watch them no I haven't watched it it's
on my list I I've watched it I won't
ruin it for you that he becomes the
governor of California not the front
door
sorry why am I even gonna watch it now
you know
perfect
[Laughter]
oh God man uh Ivor pectin you are the
best [__] in the world I don't
know no I did a quick side note before I
upload this video into onto Twitter and
we'll play it uh oh yeah I haven't
watched another documentary series which
is the welcome to wrexham which is
pretty good oh really what the hell yeah
it's uh Rob mcelmery and uh and
uh Ryan Reynolds they bought the rexham
oh yes yes okay documentary of them it's
basically it like so far it's kind of
like a real Ted lasso oh okay yeah who
likes Ted lasso then you'll you'll get I
know he almost got divorced over that or
so he says well it it was sort of they
haven't talked about it yet they talk
about the stuff in the background but um
the the joke is that
Blake Lively Ryan Ryan Reynolds wife got
super pissed that he went in because
they bought it for like two and a half
million like co-owners supposedly he
didn't tell her yeah yeah something like
that but so it's a joke but I mean she's
totally supportive of it now and like
there's clips of her like there at
rexham watching the game right right
right well I want to show you one more
clip of Bobby here Bobby and and the
reason why if you hear anyone out there
like on the left and they're saying
something about Bobby and I just know
that they're not a leftist and they're
not a liberal they're a [__] [__]
right winger who loves fascism
um because even his family's like yeah
no thanks uh listen to this listen
listen almost out of time Mr Kennedy
I'll have one last question for you you
know you mentioned your father's Legacy
I'm curious among your siblings and your
cousins who's supporting you who
supports me
um my brothers my brother Douglas
my sister Courtney
okay first off when he's like ah [__]
yeah God damn it okay
um yeah other people I can just make up
right yeah right
he likes I like Susie
Douglas loves how I cook pork chops he's
totally supportive of me I'm sorry we
have the family tree up here we don't
know who Douglas is who's Douglas Bobby
hmm right for those of you don't know
RFK Jr is not Bobby Kennedy's son yeah
RFK Jr is Ted Kennedy's son he just
called RFK Jr because he's the junior
right and am I right am I right
I'm pretty sure I'm right A lot of
people get that confused I think I don't
know really
am I right no I don't know about that
you think
Ted Ted Kennedy
had two sons Edward Kennedy Jr Patrick
Joseph Kennedy oh so this is Bobby's son
yeah
I don't know [__] I don't know
[__] I don't know but my whole family
obviously it doesn't have the best of
luck when it comes to life okay we'll
just say is there really a Douglas
oh I don't know
Robert F Kennedy Jr uh
uh
Douglas and and what what else what is
what else did he say parents Robert F
Kennedy and my brother Douglas
my sister Courtney his sister Courtney
I shouldn't I should not make fun of his
voice uh I want to okay at me how can
you know Douglas okay um that's all
I know he has a he has a speak a speech
problem so I like I won't make fun for
that [__] I'll make fun of the fact that
he's a [__] idiot can you imagine if
these right Wingers find out that he has
a speech problem
of Joe Biden for having a stutter right
and then they don't go after uh RFK Jr
for having this uh Speech problem okay
here we go 11 children holy [__] 11
children
God damn dude Bobby Bobby had eleven
Bobby the one that was shot in a hotel
running for president yeah Bobby had 11
kids Kathleen Joseph second yeah Robert
Jr Michael Carey Chris Max Douglas Rory
so Douglas is
his brother
yeah uh-huh okay okay well one person
well he's got a Wikipedia page he's a
Democrat
well yeah okay he's a journalist too is
he that's what it says what is the
Georgetown University it was born of
course he went to Brown University right
of course of course their last name is
[__] Kennedy uh uh
though he did work on the Fox News
channel
and he covered the 96 2000 2004 as well
as Hurricane Katrina
for the for Fox News
yeah though however in November 2012
Kennedy was acquitted of misdemeanor
physical harassment and child
endangerment charges in connection with
a January 7 2012 altercation with two
nurses at Northwestern Webster Hospital
in Mount Kisco New York two days after
his son Anthony boru was born there so I
guess some physical altercation I don't
know what that what happened Kenny
attempted to take his infant off the
maternity award to take some fresh air
which two nurses said I was against
Hospital policy that's why
wow that's why okay well let's listen to
see if any others relatives his dumbass
brother Doug
because you know that you know that's
the truth right and I don't know if we
got any Dougs in the audience but dude
if you're the Doug
you're the Doug
ie
you're the Doug of the family I don't
know I don't know if I know any dugs I
know a Doug funny the cartoon but that's
it well again I don't know if we got any
Dougs in the audience I'm sure we do but
if you're the Doug
you're the Doug that's why your name
that way let's listen
um
I have one sister oh yeah who sends me
notes every day oh really supportive but
she works for the Biden Administration
so I don't want it
um and then I I don't want to disclose
her name as if we're not gonna know
which sister it is what a [__]
bonehead yeah I'm not I'm not gonna I'm
not gonna outer I'm just gonna outer
yeah yeah okay if I had to look at the
the chart here is it it would have to be
Carrie I and all these other all these
other people are are boys so oh no no
Rory Rory
um let's see
so which one is it because their Bernie
may not be Kennedy anymore right well I
could still look up around Wikipedia and
see what she works for right
um activism
and Sabrina says now Tony don't diss the
Dougs I'm not dissing the Dougs I'm just
saying if your name is Doug
you're the Doug of your family that's
all I'm saying that's the truth that's
the fact I'm just saying
oh
everyone's got an Uncle Doug even if his
name's not Doug
so what what do you find as of April oh
yeah okay is there some is there some
issues here the question of do any of
your [__] siblings or family members
support you uh according
to an April April 2023 Kennedy family
back in Biden over their own in 2024 Dem
primary
yeah [__] idiots uh multiple Kennedy
family members signal that they would
not back RFK Jr in his bid for the
Democratic nominee for president I
wonder what it could be
yeah it's I I wonder I wonder I wonder
uh you know what it could be this
[__] schlub is gonna go uh speak to
moms of Liberty and he had someone on
his podcast who he deleted a tweet from
which I'm going to show you here in a
minute oh damn this is a [__] burn so
his brother Chris Kennedy
when when okay so remember there's two
11 kids two are girls uh and and nine
are boys okay that's how it broke down a
lot of kids
I don't know
in what order that happened but this is
the response that
Chris Kennedy had when who was a former
candidate in the Illinois governor's
race when he responded to CNN they said
hey what do you think about
um your brother running and he said
which brother
hahaha
he goes I love he's like this is
different
his deaf elder brother voting he has
extraordinary Charisma and is a gifted
speaker I don't know
that's questionable yeah I admire his
past work as an environmentalist because
of him we can swim in the Hudson uh but
due to a range of Bobby's positions I'm
supporting President Biden
um it could be like it could be like
all of his positions that could be it
could be yeah yeah former Maryland
lieutenant governor Kathleen Kennedy
Townsend sister to RFK Jr told CNN that
she will not talk about her brother's
bid which means she doesn't want to say
anything bad about him uh she must is
she the one writing him letters maybe is
she the one that's maybe is she the one
but she did say her brother is a part of
a misinformation campaign that is very
heartbreaking and has deadly
consequences
hmm so poor poor guy poor guy let's
let's finish up here because I want to
show you this tweet that he deleted to
yeah you know I have a lot of people my
kids my kids all support me but they
don't let's be honest here we go listen
listen a lot of them are still on
payroll at my house
that's all you need to know that's I'm
gonna stop it there
they all support all my kids support me
because honestly a lot of them are still
at the pair on the payroll at my house
oh oh oh and you want me
the canadies the elitist this is who you
want us to get the [__] out of here man
the [__] out of here the get the [__]
out of here we're getting yeah yeah
that's enough for me it's it's oh man
it's too good too good yeah I want to
show you I want to show you this uh this
tweet that he deleted
um here let's see Katelyn pointed it out
let's see
let me pull it up
um
uh he says check out my latest podcast
with Scott Ritter
on unraveling Putin's Wagner Rebellion
plus Pearson oh this is recent fog of
War yeah this is the [__]
6 25 is [__] yesterday man wow now
you see what elon's doing right two and
a half million views elon's really
really juicing the juicers juicy yeah
the same juice that [__] RFK Juniors
did right for that for that eight reps
of 115 pounds
see it has been deleted why has this
been the lead of Gabe's engines what
could possibly go wrong it's almost as
if
maybe the person that you did a podcast
with was
convicted charged or caught oh
William Scott Ritter well you hate to
see it oh the internet's forever
oh no son of a [__] he's a registered
is he a registered what is this
what is this is this a registry for
something oh oh that's weird yeah is he
where he's on a registry
he's he's got his info down so people
know they can let him up I think so yeah
it seems like um is this like a voter
registration card surely that's what
this is well no no no no because it says
offender usually when you vote you're
not offending oh who did he offend I you
know that's a good question that's good
um oh oh oh here it is at the bottom it
says unlawful contact with minor huh
okay well was that with Bobby hmm
well Bobby had him on a show because you
know he's an expert in in everything
Putin and producer apparently got it you
can not ever take
an accusation right from the Republican
party without expecting that most of the
time it's gonna be a confession of some
sort
of
and as Steve you know points out uh you
know I'm
I'm just asking questions you know I
just I'm inquisitive right an
inquisitive mind right exactly I mean
that's what a citizen journalist does
tell them that's right that's right ask
questions right can't we ask these
questions why why is it so wrong that we
ask these questions about these
candidates and their guests on their
podcast yeah it's almost like you're
supporting the very things that those
people did right you like offenders it's
weird and speaking of offenders
and people who project their confessions
um here's Grandpa and I got a few clips
for you but here's Grandpa over the
weekend let's see what he says about uh
what what right he has the documents
phony case
well it is true
I mean it is true
in other words whatever documents the
president decides to take with him he
has the absolute right to take them he
has the absolute right to keep them or
he can give them back to Nara if he
wants he talks to them like we were
doing and he can do that if he wants
that's the law and it couldn't be more
clear
um no that that's not actually true no
that's true none of that and and I I
love that he's he he's gotten himself in
a position where he's like you know what
my best defense is is that I'm just
gonna [__] tell you the opposite of
what is true yeah I can't wait for him
to get you guys get like stories do you
guys like made up stories
mine this [__] gay this [__] he's
like those are mine right it's like it's
like a kid who can't share toys you know
in school they're like that's mine
that's my toy right uh you found a video
from PornHub yeah dude I was on the Hub
yesterday I was like I just wanted some
release man a lot of people were
circulating part of this PornHub clip
around but not the whole thing not the
whole thing I got the full yeah full
thing I got the full version full
version right here on the Tony Michaels
podcast watch
do I make you horny baby oh I'm
shagged yelling
[Music]
[Laughter]
so there's the there's the full [__]
clip of it that's crazy man
did he say did he say he was gonna come
he said he was gonna come he said
I I he said he was gonna come dude
so just just so you know Gabe Sanchez
sends me two videos uh yesterday and it
was this just the him grunting with them
with the PornHub in front and behind it
and he's like which one I'm like well
not that I know or anything no I knew I
know that I'm an expert when you do the
PornHub with the with the home PornHub
thing it goes in front that's how it
works no I know that but the problem was
I was like ah if I put it at the end
it's like a better joke and I was like
we need to tell a story here and I
remember the the clip well let's just
play one more time yeah I remember I
remember the clip of him saying I'm
gonna come and I'm like oh that's
perfect
[Music]
do I make you horny baby oh
I I'm oh [__] why is that so funny I
mean it's just I you know people love a
good fart joke I showed it to my partner
and I was like hey what do you think of
this because I usually go like oh like I
I usually will are you testing it out
like what a reaction is I test out
material with her and I'll be like
um I'll be like hey is this like
typically it starts with is this funny
right yeah you shouldn't say that you
should start there but I start with like
hey I've got you should say I found this
let me show you what do you think ignore
it then I put my hand on there right
well like I'll go to I go to my partner
and I'll say like oh do uh like it's
typically like when I'm like when I'm
writing a sketch or I'm writing what was
that I'll be like ah like I want to make
sure this like flows right and how I'm
delivering this joke and so then
yesterday I was like hey which one do
you like and then and then I played both
versions and she's like well
I like the second one where like ends on
it and then but I get that it has to be
the like the front part has to start
with it and then I was like okay I'll be
right back and then I came back with
this version and I was like how is it
and she just goes
[Music]
what's the I'm gonna come party don't
really get it no it was it was the fart
one oh it was the fart it was the fart
that that really got her well I mean I
actually uh and I'm I'm being totally
transparenter I actually emailed Stormy
Daniels PR team to see if we get her on
the podcast
well I wanted it I want to find out that
that's what actually happens yeah I mean
I I I think
apparently the internet is really
interested in this
um I'm going to show you I'm going to
show you the real the real clip here
though yeah yeah I don't want to cut you
out not uh show you no no that's fine
that's fine what happened this is the
actual clip of what happened at this um
whatever the hell it was this weekend
where he was speaking
um here he is uh Donald Trump
what's that in his hand oh I don't know
it looks like something Ted Cruz would
try to ban
oh
that's I think that's the actual clip
I'm I'm pretty sure that's the um I'm
pretty sure that's the real one I I
don't think that's been doctored in any
way no I I don't know why it would be I
mean right I don't either I don't either
kinda
now there there is a there is a can you
find me
um the clip where he of Chris Christie
getting booed
that's a hilarious clip I don't know if
I've seen this one yeah go ahead Chris
Chris Christie getting booed over the
weekend
um that's that's the next one I want to
show but while you're doing that I want
to show you
um while you're finding that one I want
to show you uh because there's a lot of
clips from this thing
whatever the hell this [__] Nazi
rally was this weekend
um but it is clear it is clear
that they are they are not leaving him
and they are not walking away from him
he is going to be their nominee here's a
clip of a grandpa in the room uh just
you know showing his dominance
[Music]
were your other candidates treated this
way
[Applause]
up the stage
[Music]
[Applause]
is in my case you feel this way because
we went for great years
so there you have it they're not leaving
him let me show you who got booed I have
already given it away but oh you got it
okay I have it I gotta here
um here that here is I'm probably gonna
turn this up because this is a C-SPAN
he's crazy why they take this [__] off
C-SPAN they should take it off the
traitor TV news networks they got better
sound
ah totally not a cult Tony right totally
not a cold well this proves that it's
wink wink wink not a cult let's see it's
a big prep in 2020. why am I running for
president United States yeah why are you
I'm running
because he's let us down are you running
though are you running can Chris
Christie run have you ever I mean run
have you ever seen him run I'm okay uh I
will say he's he's definitely a third is
there a clip of him no there's a clip of
him trying to pitch at a nationalism
yeah yeah but they're uh I'm trying to
remember him running that that's that's
the the fupa moment
um but I don't know there is that time
that he confronted the person did you
ever see that video where he confronted
the person in the stands at a baseball
game yeah oh let's pull that up let's
pull that that's probably classic Chris
Christie here's here's non-classic Chris
Christie listen to him let's do him
really trying to work the crowd here he
does a magnificent job he doesn't
understand the room that he's in I don't
think
he has let us down because he's
unwilling he's unwilling to take
responsibility for any of the mistakes
that were made
any any of the faults that he has and
any of the things that he's done
and that is not leadership everybody
that is a failure of leadership
and I you can boo all you want
but here's the thing
our pain teaches us
we have to take responsibility for what
they do people have to stand up and take
accountability for what they do
okay you can start and I
I cannot stand by and as soon as I've
started to be critical
after all of that after you offered me
white house chief of staff
now what he does is call me names
and he's been calling you names for a
year
I will tell I mean he calls
everybody's been calling him I mean he
was making fun of him last year for
[__] if whether or not that was
actually Chris Christie at 11 p.m at a
buffet right so like he's been [__]
going after him for a year now so the
idea that he's like oh he's just going
after me now because I'm running for
president it's because he let us down
dude no man
you were back at him in 2020 when you're
helping him prepare for the God damn
debate
he almost killed you and you still were
like huh thank you oh damn that's loud
sorry all right hang on let me get my
boy adjusted [__] you do you send me
YouTube then well it's not on Twitter
man so I gotta put on it well it happens
it happens so this is this is at a Cubs
game yeah yeah and this is CNN thing so
they tell you kind of the background
what happened okay listen
[Music]
appreciate that
by the way this happens a lot with Cubs
fans I'm just saying I don't know if you
know any Cubs fans but they're [__]
okay thank you hey hey hey
this is what they do they come to
baseball games they come to baseball
games
they act like a total [__] [__]
they'll come to Busch Stadium when
they're not even playing they're not
even playing that goddamn stadium and
they're just a bunch of [__]
just a [__] bunch of hooligans and
goddamn Cubs fans so I don't blame I'm
sorry um
getting all up in that motherfucker's
face
obviously I'm a Cardinals fan and yeah
Gabe is a Cubs fan that's why we're
having the back and forth is better than
Mark McGuire [__] oh really Mr cork bat
come on man oh my God hemroids
much rather have a roid head listen yeah
if we're gonna idolize roid heads let's
idolize Roy heads okay let's just do
that here's let's let's see what
sorry I didn't mean to get our um our
beef uh in a complex here with the show
important
[Music]
this is
when he initially was going up the
stairs I yelled his name and then I told
him that he sucked but I called him a
hypocrite because I thought
um you know I needed to be sad all right
all right maybe Cubs fans aren't that
bad I mean maybe not sorry maybe I mean
we we tell it like it is baby I guess so
[Music]
I guess Chris Christie told him to have
another beer yeah
and here he is in his face
[Music]
Ingrid service why would he have Secret
Service what are they talking about you
mean it's security detail okay I haven't
had enough of this hey we just gets in
this guy's face because this guy calls
Chris Christie because Chris Christie is
an [__] I mean as much as Cubs fans
are [__] and I can confirm that for
sure yeah they're total [__] this is
from five years ago so oh really so this
was when he was the governor why was he
at a [__] Brewers because his son his
his son works
for the Brewers yeah oh okay
so that seems a long ways away from New
Jersey that's all I'm saying I guess I
guess if you got free tickets the
exactly yeah he just works I don't know
what position but he works for the
Brewers so that's why he was there I see
I see I mean there's also another clip
where he caught a fall a foul ball and
everyone booed him that's funny
this has a lot of trouble he has a lot
of trouble like it's just like you know
him Ted Cruz these people think they can
go to these games
in these areas that are not
like they're not Republican they're
Democratic in their in their demographic
right so when they show well again
they're like in cities and [__] yeah
they're in cities the very same people
have to like cooperate and they have to
you know the very same thing [__] on
right right they're like these blue
these blue States these blue cities uh
those people where they make all their
money and pay their taxes so we can get
Federal subsidies here in our red areas
they you know and it's like what do you
think is going to happen when you come
to these cities and you try to like
after [__] on them you know you
don't you know what's going to happen
you know what's going to happen right
what's up they're gonna say something to
you just like death angel here said
something to Jordan Peterson so the
Democrats tweeted out the number one
cause of death for children in America
is gun violence enough is enough Jordan
Peterson that cuck he decided to say
actually actually
actually
it's abortion by huge margin uh death
angel said actually
uh the number uh by a a far margin is
showing us that uh uh the debts are by
abortion not by gun violence
so Death Angel decides to point out here
um another fact if you want to call it
that she says if he's facts man you're
going to hurt someone Jordan Peterson
thinks that abortions are murders and
deaths so she decides to point out it's
actual it's actually actually it's
actually the countless babies your
followers pumping the socks every day
absolutely absolutely destroying Jordan
Peterson I found this this morning I'm
like oh my God this is most fantastic
thing I've ever I've seen all day so I
found that this morning so thank you uh
Death Angel for
showing Jordan Peterson and the way out
the door
okay what else do we get we got a couple
minutes left oh hey did you know
well apparently Lauren bobert went to
practice wrestling some alligators or
something what the [__] is this [__] no
I did not know that I don't know shut
the front door after she lost her
[__] impeachment vote I well I mean
um Patriot takes or has it here it says
Warren buffer practicing God bless
patriotics her next Swamp Creature
confrontation on the house floor
I mean there she is wow look at her in a
[__] high heel yeah boot shooting
things well at Patriot front our Patriot
excuse me takes Jesus Christ he
questioned this and they said um
probably not the best yeah boom see I'm
glad I'm glad they pointed out it makes
no [__] sense well Hey listen listen
if we're gonna mix all the sense of a
republican well if you're Gator food
this is the proper gear that you would
wear if you're Gator food okay so maybe
she was just going for the Gator food
look it's awesome maybe maybe maybe
maybe maybe maybe maybe we got one more
one more thing I wanna I wanna I wanna
[__] on [__] Greg Abbott oh yeah yeah
I got it here I got it yeah okay all
right okay um uh so this is a
so there's who's the [__] guy that
quotes this thing all the time it's
called it's called Dunn and Kruger times
it's hilarious I sent it to you I don't
know last week I was like these people
are serious it's done at cougar times
now this goes back to the Garth Brooks
story oh my God I cannot believe we have
to
relive this nonsense okay so if you
don't know CMA Fest was a couple weeks
ago and it's when it's where tens of
thousands of people go to Nashville to
celebrate CMA Fest and they have huge
live shows and there's bars and downtown
Nashville and Garth Brooks has a bar
there it's called
Friends in Low Places I don't know if
you heard of Garth Brooks before but
he's got a popular song that's
called friends in low places so it's
never Garth Brooks yeah he sounds
[__] gay
well wow he is he is apparently to these
Alpha Cooks kind of gay so Garth Brooks
tells these Alpha Cooks hey you can be
bigots that's fine you can be [__]
is the word he used yeah but you can't
be that in my bar because I'm gonna
serve Bud Light rather you like it or
not so if you don't like it fine
whatever on guard Brooks I got more
money than you'll ever [__] dream of
right go on down the road someplace else
I don't need your you want to go to Kid
Rock's Bar you can have a Bud Light
there go ahead this done in Kruger times
keeps running these stories about Garth
Brooks that are totally [__] false
and how you know they're false is
they're in the dun and Krueger died done
in Kruger times I don't know if you know
what Dunning Krueger means but they're
mocking you you [__] idiots so the
headline years for the dun and
careertimes.com is Garth Brooks boot off
stage at the 123rd annual Texas how many
I don't know how many Republicans
including uh
including
great habit
tweeted that I don't know but the
governor you know that's um that's my
that's a good question
but the governor of Texas decided this
was real oh my God and he [__]
tweeted about it he says he repeats it
he repeats the [__] from the [__]
headline of the dunging kerger
times.com folks he says Garth Brooks
boot off stage at 123rd is it really the
123rd annual Texas country Jamboree is
that even a [__] thing can you look
that up
123rd annual think about that because
one two three it just feels like it's
it's [__] not real I mean
I mean the Texas country Jamboree may be
real but 123 dudes come on I know I know
come on country music hasn't it's been
around for a while but 123 and annual
years he [__] dingling yeah they're
like oh man he got booed for 90 seconds
like no no
okay so he goes on to say he goes on to
say
um he's trying to compete with uh Ron
DeSantis of how many times he can put
the word woke in his um rhetoric here he
says go woke
go broke
um he also says Garth calls his
conservative fans [__] no he just
called uh bigots like you Greg Abbott
yeah an [__] he called you an [__]
good job Texas well problem is his dude
deleted this and the reason why he
deleted this is because it's [__]
fake it's not real it's not real it says
here here's Greg here not to be confused
with Greg Abbott Greg Caster says just
accidentally post a satire article I
don't know how you don't know this is
[__] satire and they're posting these
articles like literally if you go search
this website on Twitter you'll see all
these right Wingers posting this I just
sent you a couple okay good which also
also goes to show you that
I'm pretty sure they don't know how to
read
well this is easy Google and you don't
have to Google it 123rd annual like how
are you you're so [__] stupid okay it
says um because he wants to hate on
queer Texans and Garth Brooks so [__]
bad and he said it's a great Caster
continues here he says the Texas uh
country Jamboree doesn't exist actually
it's not real and the governor is not
fit to tweet much less govern happy
Pride I couldn't agree more but here's
some more examples uh let's see let's
see if this is in are these [__]
idiots falling for this um this satire
publication because that's what it is
it's satire it's not real they say it in
the name oh this one says it's been
deleted yeah that's because it was quote
tweeting Greg Abbott oh okay okay so
this is a quote tweet from Cassie here I
think that's Cassie
um Texans show Garth Brooks Alex again
when you call conservous [__] you'd
be greeted with booze even though it
didn't actually happen listen no one is
paying I don't know you know how much a
Garth Brooks concert ticket is uh I
don't know not only could they not
convince Garth Brooks to go play at a
fake ass Jamboree that doesn't exist but
I would almost bet and I think it's only
concerts that he has right now is in in
Vegas because he has a huge contract and
I I would bet that a [__] concert
ticket right now there is [__]
hundreds of dollars sitting the [__]
nosebleed actually you know small world
the the shoot that I was on for the
commercial I was working on uh two weeks
ago or less than two weeks ago
um I was like oh what project are you
guys working on next and they're like
actually we have to go film all these
commercials with Garth Brooks and we've
got actually actually uh and they're
like we're gonna go meet him in Vegas
it's crazy I was like because you and I
just talked about him yes listen I've
tried to actually full transparency I've
tried to get in contact with Garth
Brooks team because I would like to
[__] interview him about this not not
this these specific uh incident of the
Bud Light in the bar but the overall
[__] talk about this because Garth
Brooks has been openly uh an ally of the
lgbtq community since the late 80s early
90s he said it out loud in public in
interviews and it's because his sister
is half-sister
was was gay and he supported her because
he knew her I mean he knew she wasn't a
demon he knew she was just a person and
this is just who she was and she loved
someone and he didn't judge her for that
and he found out through that personal
experience that yeah it said they're not
demons right and we can support these
people real humans they're a Human Being
Human who'd have thought who'da thunk it
they're human beings
but uh so yeah we we have tried to reach
out to Garth um I I had a little bit of
success but nothing back yet here's
another here's another what's this one
here is this a different one oh no this
is just someone reposting that they take
a screenshot of it
so this is Marcia Marcia thinks she's
really clever here
oh my God look at her handle Marshall
and magadonian
s so she really is proud that she's
hashtag does she know that that Mega
don't never mind I'm not even gonna no
they think
they think sis is a slur so I'm not
gonna get into what megalodonian is
um
she loves that he's cancer listen folks
this you would have to believe that they
paid hundreds of dollars for these
tickets to go boo him off stage yeah
okay again that is not the proper way to
cancel someone it is the same [__] as
you gotta buy cans and cases of Bud
Light and shoot it with machine gun
AR-15 type [__] or you have to buy a
Jersey to burn it or you have to buy
this thing like a phone or whatever it
might be that you're trying to boycott
slash cancel
again Eminem's another example they
don't [__] care you gave them your
money
deals done transaction over whatever you
do with the thing that you bought from
them
go do it they don't [__] care
but whenever you see people on the right
who are like oh man we're gonna own them
we're gonna boycott them by buying the
thing and then we're gonna crush and
Destroy and it's like I mean that sounds
like it's a waste of money but hey man
go for it
well I I don't know if you know this but
the the song Friends in Low Places it
has a third verse okay there's two
verses that's like the album version and
then there's the live version that Garth
does and it's there's a third verse and
at the end of the third verse it goes
it goes like this
um he says
um
and I'll show uh uh let's start here uh
well I guess I was wrong I just don't
belong but then I've been there before
and everything is all right I'll just
say good night and I'll show myself to
the door
hey didn't mean to cause a big scene
just wait till I finish this glass of
Bud Light apparently then sweet little
lady I'll head back to the bar and you
can kiss my ass I don't know if these
are Garth Brooks's pronouns or not but
uh Marsha I think Garth Brooks is
telling you in this song that you can
you can kiss his ass that's all that's
all I'm saying all right before we head
out I just wanna I just want to laugh at
this because now it's like my man I
gotta do what was that how much is it
click that link and I went all the way
to July 23rd because I was like oh just
in case like the July 4th weekend is
going to be expensive [__] me look at
those prices Jesus Christ okay so this
is the mezzanine now this is the theater
in Vegas right yeah is that right yeah I
believe so what what is this uh what
What's the it's the Coliseum it's easy
as well the Coliseum at Caesar's Palace
right so that's that's the auditorium
the the stadium that they're in
um this is the mezzanine for anyone
who's never been to a concert before
where's the mezzanine Gabe Sanchez where
is it it's not the ground floor it's
above that right
so the mezzanine in section 406 is 384
dollars uh that's two tickets uh Road J
um there's four one to four or six
tickets it's four and three if you want
eight tickets in Row D so you're a
little closer and I'm by a little closer
I mean by feet uh
um like six feet maybe
um 410 if you want to get to G it's 420
e is for 21. there's a couple and
there's six tickets in Row D and the
mezzanine now this is the second
mezzanine so I'm guessing the first
mezzanine is like the first level right
the second one the second one is even
farther look at the Go click on the map
yeah well here let me I gotta zoom out
so here's the so so here here is where
Garth Brooks
here is where Garth Brooks this is where
Garth Brooks would be yeah on on the
stage okay so that's where he would be
now he would also I don't know if you
know this he would have a microphone and
I mean it would be loud yeah like he's
got a band and they're all miked I mean
it's [__] loud in this place right
it's almost like they're doing a concert
or something right yeah crazy okay so
um and then there's section 100 there's
the twos okay so you got then you've got
the orchestra area right and then you
get the mezzanine
the first one yeah yeah the first one
which again you can oh my God if you
scroll to the okay everyone has an image
of this right now what we've gone first
we've gone through right now are the
most affordable the the cheapest which
is in the 400s which is in the 400 which
is this first mezzanine section in the
second now go back to the prices and
scroll all the way to the bottom
here we go here we go let's see this is
the front Orchestra
1853 each
uh if you want to sit in the front
orchestra that way you may have a chance
if you want to boo him and he still
won't hear he's not he's not gonna hear
you and the reason why Garth Brooks
didn't get any reboons because he got
earpieces in too yeah he's got here
music and he's like great I'm on I'm on
track with what I'm supposed to be doing
right he doesn't give a [__] but also if
you try to boo he's like you just paid
me 1800 bucks to come like boom when no
one hears me and that's not only that
but like he obviously gets paid by
Caesar's Palace to be there right he's
got his residency for however long he's
there so he gets paid that way and then
he makes a percentage of what the ticket
sales are so he's [__] double dipping
and also funny also I don't know if the
audience knows this who Garth Brooks is
he's [__] who did he's [__] rich
man he's got more money he doesn't need
to sing anymore he doesn't have to do
this [__] anymore he doesn't want to he
retired at one point point he retired at
one point he's like no I ain't gonna do
that [__] no more and then he's like you
know what [__] I'll sing for these
people if they're gonna pay me a couple
thousand dollars yeah whatever I'll do
that especially if they're gonna come
and boo me that'd be awesome yeah
um somebody was wondering what's the
seating capacity let's see uh Coliseum
for the Coliseum uh yeah that's a good
question
Coliseum and this is for this is the
date um of July 23rd so it's kind of
like you said it's and it's an 8 P.M
show is what this is yeah so what's
occupancy in holy [__]
how many how many
wow uh it has a the venue opened in 2003
and has an estimated seating capacity of
4 100 spectators
okay now I haven't broken down the
individual seats in the front area but
let's say that let's say that the first
two orchestras are
um more than half okay right yeah so
it's probably 2500 yeah which means that
you know those tickets are selling for
over a thousand bucks a pop for over 50
so we'll say over 2 000 seats are a
thousand bucks a pop right and then the
other ones are for 300 400 500 600 bucks
right it's making a lot of money there
right lots of money it's I mean Celine
Dion she had the longest residency and
she was there for 1100 shows the
Coliseum yeah yeah and how long because
how long is garth's contract with the
Coliseum because he's he's I and you
just signed it last year I think yeah
um let's see because he was
he had
well let's see let's see it's easy how
long how long is and you gotta have a
big name at the at this Coliseum yeah if
you're gonna sell because you gotta
bring thousand every [__] yeah I mean
they're selling out four thousand like
probably two three times a week yeah I'm
missing like once a month that they're
doing this
um let's see
how long is a residency there okay so it
says uh ahead of the opening night in
Garth Brooks Las Vegas residency that
comes already announced that is plus
ones uh plus one staying at the Coliseum
and Caesar's Pals will extend into
2024. when they went on sale he said he
felt extremely fortunate and blessed so
he's going into next year man right like
right this is over a year right so so
the dude's gonna make enough money in
the next year to have enough money for
the rest of his life probably okay you
booing him at some fake ass Jamboree in
Texas that he didn't play at you dummies
it's not is and and you not going to his
bar in Nashville his bar now I'm not
going there but like it'll make you gay
and he doesn't give a [__] and you want
to know why it was extended so it looks
like it was originally 27 then they
added 18 shows and then
uh
it was Bud Light like hey we'll sponsor
you please yeah sold sold out it's
because
the first 20 the overwhelming demand for
tickets in his first 27 shows so they
extended it to into 2025. oh no no he's
not
he's not angelidonian ordinary no
extraordinary demand Tony use fake news
news fake news fake news
extraordinary demand due to
extraordinary demands motor at Live
Nation okay the person who's running the
ticket sales for the coliseum in other
words what does extraordinary demand
mean what does that mean exactly it
means that there's an overwhelming
amount of people who want tickets but
can't get tickets so they say you know
what it is you know what it is I bet
there's an overwhelming demand to pay
two thousand dollars to go boo guard
Brooks because he likes gay beer that's
what it is 100 100
blame it all in my rooms should have
moons and ruined your black tie fear oh
my God I can't believe these idiots
really think that Garth Brooks is
canceled so Marcia you're a [__]
idiot you're a [__] idiot keep them
coming we love it here at the Tony
Michaels podcast you give us tons of
content every single every single week
every single weekday just right here on
YouTube don't do not forget to subscribe
yup to these Tony Michaels podcast here
on YouTube also on Twitter at Tony
Michaels pod you can watch it on
Facebook as well at the Tony Michaels
you can also follow us over on Twitch
for free twitch.tv Tony Michaels also
download every single episode in the
afternoon on Apple Spotify and Google
it's free 99 there Gabe to download it
in here
look if you want to boo us didn't cost
you any money I mean right get it right
[__] you can Boo the [__] out of us in
the chat whether it's on YouTube twitch
Facebook I don't give a [__] hell leave
a comment comment on the [__]
directories do it I don't Char I'm not
like Garth I do not charge you to
[__] boo me yeah it's free you can
come here and boo us all you want and
come back tomorrow you [__] haters
and boo us because we'll be here
same time same place
Surf's Up [__] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[__] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn hadass Beacon
do I make you horny baby oh I'm
very shaggedellic ah
foreign